got a Shad he he was dropping a new uh
Shad line so let's give him
some let's give him some these the
shades I'm give you
these I just want to see how y'all
look
[Music]
good I like
uh they don't realize not only we going
to kick their butts because it's it's
it's personal but it's going to be
business but it's also pleasure when I
say business uh blenders I do a line
shades with blenders this is one of the
first lines so they don't realize they
just help me with
business5 million of glasses and that's
a lot that's crazy though that's how it
be he had that entire team with
sunglasses the glasses tough though I
like the glasses it look
good